on ne bouge pas pendant le single
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien alors ben justement donc comme vous
êtes acteur on va vous faire
le questionnaire de proust normal cela
pète on se la pète pas pour vous stomy
bugzy c'est quoi le comble de la misère
de la misère la galère soulevées ne pas
pouvoir nourrir ses enfants
ouais et vous de jamais pouvoir en
sortir
ouais pour quelle faute avez-vous le
plus d'indulgence ça vous apprendra le
mensonge peut pas nous c'est pas le
mensonge
ouais et vous aurez pareil
quel est votre personnage historique
favori
là où l'autre malcom x où martin luther
king benbella votre peintre favori
en tout cas c'est les impressionnistes
peut-être sézanne
ouais ouais oui j'y connais rien à la
qualité que vous préférez chez l'homme
bon courage et vous
ainsi par ailleurs non non je n'en ai
pas parlé de courage non c'est pas des
qualités que je préfère chez l'homme
aucune non je suis et chez la femme que
vous respirez peut-être et la
sensibilité et vous stomie la fidélité
n'ont par contre pas dit pour la ville
la vie pour la femme qui auriez-vous
aimé être
si vous n'étiez pas stomy bugzy qui par
exemple j'ai pas soit mes cartes à brad
le libre et libérateur du cap vert où
sera le pacino al pacino et vos mots de
personnes wallon roulettes vous ouais je
suis bien moins dans le mois mais
nerveux très bien votre principal défaut
la plagne à naples c'est pour ça que
c'est compliqué mais plein de défauts
j'ai pas choisi répond d'abord l'asie
tient cherche et cherche un peu mon
principal défaut c'est que je pense que
je relativise beaucoup trop ça m'empêche
de d'être vraiment content que oui
c'était naturel un peu sombre non pas
sont justement non je suis je suis très
drôle normalement mais si c'est vrai qu
est ce qu est ce qui nous arrive c'est
sincèrement je suis très devrait
normalement j'aime rire mais mais je
relativise beaucoup et ça m'empêche de
de vivre pleinement ce que je fais pas
votre principal défaut stomie je sais
pas non je ne sais pas là tellement
c'est fastoche établissant un droit mais
[Musique]
des gourmands départ et se tait coureurs
mais non non non c'est est arrivé en
retard ne sais pas non non je sais pas
franchement je sais pas défaut ça c'est
leur cas changer le don de la nature que
vous voudriez avoir et que vous n'avez
pas voulu voler vous l'avez déjà fermée
des questions à battants qui déjoue
acteurs moi je te la joues marcel proust
ainsi car ça t'apprendra t'inquiète pas
je vais revenir l'an prochain pour un
album hattrick avant foutent la merde
ici
votre devise yazid n'a rien sans rien
ouais mais vous baise la vie chinois de
besoin ou là les cours est sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous il m'était impossible